[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
richard jefferson espn nba analyst
yes network nets analyst nba
champ with the cavs joining us from
milwaukee richard thanks for joining us
i was just talking to the danettes about
shooting underhand if i had said to shaq
or some of these other players who
struggle hey you can make
75 of your free throws but you gotta
shoot underhand
how many guys do you think would be
willing to do that in a game
um i think i i don't know i
i think it takes more courage to do that
uh
because i think you're you're already
having to deal with people
making fun of you because you shoot 58
and you're going
you know bricking every free throw so
you know it's just all about
self-confidence in those moments because
you know you're going to make 75 but
you actually might get more heat than
you will from just shooting normal free
throws but isn't that interesting that
you would rather
be embarrassed in a different way than
like if i'm going to be embarrassed i'd
rather be embarrassed
in succeeding than in failure
yeah that that that was the ultimate
conversation between billy hoyle
and and sydney dean he's like i know who
you are you'd rather
look you'd rather look good and play bad
than play bad and look good
a white man can't jump reference there
all right
so you had uh firsthand great view
uh front row seat when lebron had his uh
you know his chase down blocking andre
iguodala
in the nba finals and then you were
there last night with what uh giannis
did to deandre ayton
better drop uh better block to you was
which one
uh very different i think giannis's
blocking game one was closer because it
was the same it was
a chase down the difference is it's what
makes both of those blocks so special
and so unique
is the time in which they happened right
the time in which they happened the
moment in the game the moment
in the series so if we're talking about
you know
a more impressive block it's definitely
broad
because the the it meant more the time
of it a minute to go in a game seven
you know down three one all this uh if
you're talking about
how many people on the planet could go
do what somebody did
then that's the giannis block because
there's only maybe two players
that can be backtracking heart hand up
turn around see the lob go up one two go
get it against the the
the number one pick that's seven feet in
athletic deandre ayton it was
technically perfect and it was
physically only three people in the
world can do that so it's like the
combination is what made that so special
what was the huddle like after lebron
had that block against iguodala
i i kid you not i kid you not in
seven after the seven games and all this
other stuff
that was the first time i thought oh
we're gonna win this but i kid you not
because it was back and forth
and everyone knows and everyone's talked
about that game and it's one of the more
dissected series
but it was like that was the first
moment where i was like oh wait we're
gonna win this
because it was like now the time was
running out now it's becoming a one-two
possession game
we had the ball you know and it was like
okay what are we going to draw what are
we going to do because
at that moment we had control it becomes
like that it becomes that free throw
time game you can look and see like well
we're even if we
miss and they score we're going to get a
second chance so like we're in control
right now this is the first time
in the entire series that we were in
control and it was like a minute
to go did lebron say anything in the
huddle
no i think that's when they were talking
about trying to get the ball to kyrie
trying to get steph on him
uh that was the difference for us is
trying to get stefan more pick and rolls
because the warriors defense was so
impeccable
uh with draymond you know helming it and
andre and those guys and
clay you have three basically all first
team defenders
on that roster and so uh trying to get
steph in it
uh not that you know steph led the
league and steals not that steph can't
play defense but that was one of those
small advantages that you might have and
so got kyrie and the rest of
the rest was history dame lillard
tweeted in real time last night after
the uh giannis block
that giannis just won the game for them
even though there was a little over a
minute to go
that like i'm always curious what
happens after a big play
or somebody gives up a home run or
somebody gets uh you know a long
touchdown pass
that to me where it kind of it it's it's
you you just took a punch from tyson
because you're like wait a minute what
we were going to tie this up with a dunk
and it could have gone the other way
richard whereas like
we just dunked on the greek freak and
now there's momentum with phoenix there
and you just survived a questionable
call with devin booker
not getting uh called for the foul
against holiday i don't know
we'd be talking a whole different uh
game today if phoenix had won that
and we would be looking back on that
dunk in a different way
a hundred percent and it's like you know
what i'm wondering where's all that
conversation now about
oh scott foster and oh you know
questionable foul calls and it's like
wait a second
i want i want the same people that were
complaining about giannis's 17 free
throws
when nobody else on his team shot more
than three and you're questioning the
officiating now all of a sudden you're a
guy that's got 40 points you're all nba
guy your olympian
should have fouled out on the road and
didn't you're not you're if you're not
gonna
if you're going to complain about the
officials here recognize that this goes
both ways that's why i put very little
stock
unless it's overly glaring and i'm not
talking about an
overall record when one referee coaches
one player
i'm not talking about any of that
nonsense i'm talking about
overall there are things that go both
ways for you when you add human error or
mistakes
into those situations but yeah we would
be looking at this series
very very differently but the key thing
about what people don't understand is
that
it's momentum and it's momentum within
quarters it's momentum within games and
it's momentum within
series so that play
gave them the momentum in the game
because it was so
so much late so it was you know one one
and change and then it helped gave them
momentum in the series
so there's like a domino effect and now
it's their job to maintain it and it's
phoenix's job to slow it down
it's richard jefferson espn nba analyst
joining us from milwaukee
what is it like when you're guarding a
star and you didn't do anything
but you still get whistled for a foul
it you know what it's it's it's expected
it's expected you know that there's
there's part of your role
and depending on who you are there's
guys like tj tucker patrick bevley
you know um you know guys that are known
as defensive
uh players that they'll get away with
more
they'll get away with more than than
other defensive players
uh just you know draymond greens one of
them uh but
when you're guarding those guys you know
it you have to understand ever since we
were
12 years old you try your best and
someone's just better
right it doesn't matter if you're in
college it doesn't matter if you're in
high school or when you get to the pros
like i had to guard kevin durant in the
finals
you know else i've had to guard in the
finals kobe bryant it's not a lot of fun
guys
it's not a lot of fun right there's
certain days where you're like well
you know well screw it i tried okay
who would you rather guard out of those
two at their peak
i don't know because for kobe there was
there was something about it where it's
like he wanted to take your soul so you
felt like it wasn't like he just wanted
to score on you
he also wanted to look you in the eye
while he was doing it
where like kevin durant just you're like
well there's nothing i can do like like
just the physical like like attributes
that this guy has on 2k wouldn't even be
allowed
but durant doesn't do any talking i'm
sure kobe was talking
exactly but this is what i'm saying
kevin durant is more unguardable
than kobe right he's more unguardable
and that's why kobe was a ridiculous
offensive weapon but
understand this that i'm not talking
trash about kobe of all the top five
scorers he was the least efficient so he
took the most shot
i think he missed more shots than
anybody in nba history he took more
more shots to get to those points where
kevin durant is one of the most
efficient scores in the
that is i don't think he's in the top 10
eventually he'll be in all those numbers
but
he's one of the most efficient guys
especially from the perimeter
to be on that list so it's like how do
you want do you want a guy that's going
to shoot 35 shots and try and take your
soul or do you want a guy that's going
to shoot 18
shots and you're just like he doesn't
miss this guy just doesn't miss what do
you want me to do
do you still do you hold a beef against
anybody a grudge
are you mad at anybody that you played
against
uh if i do i wouldn't i wouldn't say it
i wouldn't say it because any beef that
i had
any beat that i have a lot of it had to
do with less about basketball
and more about and because like
basketball beef is kind of like a
frustrating it's a playing
like i can't send shane battier and jay
will because they beat me
when i was in the national championship
game but anything like
anything that like gets past that if
there's any real beef is because there
was something that was probably
a line that was crossed and you know
we'll just keep those between the lines
are you um you know when you lose that
game
is jay will is he allowed to brag to you
like
how often does that come up where
somebody goes remember the national
title game or i i i bring it up
nine times out of ten when we're around
each other so because you know it does
it validates me being mean to him or me
cracking jokes with him or me just you
know messing with him a little bit
but no man it's a competitive thing it
really is like
there are people that you still like
genuinely you're just like look i'll be
professional especially in this industry
now that we're in the broadcast booth
i'll be professional but yeah yeah
there's definitely there's always going
to be beefs that that never leave
that's just part of what's ingrained in
us i i also
one thing i've been bringing up all
morning long is if i factor in where
giannis was
a couple of weeks ago where he had that
hyper-extended knee
richard and you know i had guys who had
the channing fry said i
i don't think he plays again like i've
had that injury at six weeks
the fact that he had that injury
and he did what he did last night and
what he's doing in the finals
i i don't know if people have truly
talked about that even if you don't have
the injury to do what he did last night
and then you factor in the injury and
they had the wherewithal to go i'm going
to go up there and try to get this
and then actually get that block um you
got to factor in
the knee well you have to fight but it
was like
the first game you can see that he was
still just testing it out
and him testing out his knee was 20 and
15.
right and then once he felt comfortable
with his knees like all right it's time
to go to work
and he it and you know that was just the
confidence is this me probably 100
but i'm not going to talk about a knee
when you've gone back to back 40 point
games i refuse to talk about your knee
i'll applaud you i'll recognize the fact
that you did that
after missing a week but i'm not going
to and you know what's crazy
is sometimes when you have that type of
injury and i'm not this is not a
positive but you have to find the silver
lining
the rest of your body gets rested you
look at chris paul in this series
or in the last five games he went from
like 41 to 33
to 22 to 19 to to whatever he had last
night
every single game he's gotten worse
statistically
including the turnovers from last game
so you look at it and you could see
statistically
it looks like he's wearing down where
all of a sudden you get giannis a a weak
break
where the rest of his body can relax his
muscles can
can recover all of the things and don't
forget he's called the greek freak
at 26 years old you can literally stab
yourself
in the leg with a knife pull it out then
watch it
heal in real time that's what happens
when you're that young and especially
when you're a physical
specimen like him we don't recommend
that by the way for anybody who's
no no no no no only only only giannis
can do that well i'm not i'm not this is
a scientific experiment it's been proven
there's like eight guys in history that
can heal that quickly
all right monty williams has a decision
to make on what you do with chris paul
because i
i do love the bucks and drew holiday
picking him up three-quarters court and
making him work a little bit more
so uh what kind of pressure is chris
paul facing here
this next game he's facing a ton
and you know i'll we'll go into the
archives and i'll give you an example
uh my first year in in uh in cleveland
obviously i'm an idiot
my first year in san antonio we played
against jason kitten he was with dallas
they were the two seed and jason kidd
was
a older point guard very similar you
would never dare
pick up chris paul you would never dare
pick up jason kidd
but once you pick those guys up right
because a lot of times you give them
that respect
but once you pick them up they view it
as disrespect but they don't have the
same motor at 32 and at 28.
so now all of a sudden you see them
wearing down and what's so crazy
is that they're wearing he's wearing
down with two days rest
and we're going to say wearing down
we're going to say wearing down
because god knows we don't want to say
is chris paul getting nervous
is chris paul just squeezing on too
tight
because we've seen this before we've
seen this over the course of his career
to be so close to the mountaintop so
close to the conference finals
so close to the nba finals now so close
to a championship
and all of a sudden you start to see
some weird things like some of these
turnovers
like these weren't wearing down these
were turnovers that were very
uncharacteristic of a person of his
caliber
at the highest of moments so don't be
surprised if over the next 48 hours you
start to hear
is chris paul getting nervous is chris
paul starting to become clipper chris
paul
is this starting to become houston chris
paul that's what you're going to start
hearing over the next 48 hours so chris
paul has a lot
to think about and digest and i think
all
of the pressure falls on the phoenix
suns in this moment
great stuff richard we appreciate your
time safe travels thanks for joining us
dan such a huge fan man thanks for
having me i gotta give a shout out to my
guy sully he was excited when he found
out that i was going to be on your show
awesome thank you thank you sully
uh richard jefferson the mothership
analyst and uh yes
network analysts with the nets also won
a championship with lebron